thank you okay stormy you're 28 points
ahead in the polls reflecting both
dissatisfaction with the current
government people want their country to
work but can you honestly say that your
Blue Sky Thinking rather than clear
specific policies such as cutting work
in people's taxes or ensuring that
they'll get a Hospital appointment is in
any way relatable
does this risk turn in off even angering
people that you need to vote for you and
given that you've ditched policies such
as scrapping tuition fees and
nationalized and energy companies the
policies that you want the labor
leadership on why should anyone believe
anything you say anyway thank you uh
Beth look thank you for that question I
mean on this central question
um we we do tend to go round and round
you're quite right to say look what's
what are you gonna do about the NHS this
winter what are you going to do about
energy bills this spring and we have to
answer that question I accept that and
that's why we do have answers to those
questions why we were the first to lead
on freezing energy bills but the problem
if we stop there with that sort of
retail offer for the here and now is
that we'll never fix the fundamentals
and therefore next year we'll be back in
an NHS crisis and you'll be sitting here
Beth and you'll ask me the same question
what are you gonna do about the here and
now and probably the year after and the
year after we go round and round in
circles sticking class to politics but
that's why we've got to fix it for the
NHS if we don't have more medical
students more nurses and doctors coming
through then we will never get out of
this cycle and therefore this long term
has to be harnessed with the short term
missions for a mission-led government
same old energy to be perfectly honest
freezing the bills this year and then
you'll come back next year and say well
we're going to freeze the bills next
during the year after
and the answer is we do have to do that
that's why we LED on that policy but we
also have to have a better answer for
energy security energy bills in the
future and that's why running toward
Renewables having our you know net
energy by Clean energy by 2030 is so
important and that's the frustration I
mean we've had 13 years of sticking past
to politics we've had 13 years of going
round and round in circles always ending
up in the same place and never moving
forward and this is absolutely needed
and I do I reject the argument that the
public don't get it everybody knows in
their own life that you do fix a problem
when it comes to maybe your pipes or
your car or whatever it is but everybody
knows you've also got to fix the
fundamentals otherwise you'd just be
back in the same place at the end of the
exercise and that's what this is about
and you know all you've got you know
from the government frankly is sort of
short-term promises to clear up their
own mess these are long-term missions
for National renewal thank you Beth um
Chris
from BBC
on the on the trust issue look I think
anybody looking at these missions will
realize that they're hard thought
through they reflect the really big
challenges of the country and they come
each of them not just with the mission
which is really ambitious hard to
achieve but also with the underpinning
the specifics that are needed as to how
they're going to be achieved and
actually for each of them with the first
steps what are you going to do as it
were from day one and we'll set those
out obviously for the economy we've
already set them out for Net Zero we've
set them out and we'll do that for the
other missions